the Joe Rogan experience you know he
used to do that at the roast was greg
Giraldo yes he would go out and he would
just say the [ __ ] then even in a Rosie
be like Oh [ __ ] he goes first
well people hadn't even had drinks yet
you and me like he said um iced tea
you're so old you used your first
residual check to buy your freedom like
Jesus bunny
that would be like his opening joke oh
my god it was like 5:30 on a Sunday it
was like homie like he would just come
sort and the audience wouldn't even know
what to do but that's something he was
so [ __ ] unbelievable like Greg and I
were on TV at the same time and we were
right next to each other on the lot at
Gower sunset and Gower yeah I was a news
radio and he had his own show for a bit
in his show was right next to my show
and we would hang out you know cuz we're
we're both guys from New York that were
more from the East Coast at least that
we're doing comedy and we're out here
like things crazy you know and and I
never thought he would die like that
like when he died of a drug overdose I
was like Greg we had been sober yeah
what happened he went to a party and
someone gave him some [ __ ] and I mean
it's so tricky when my I mean I get
worried I'm like a [ __ ] mom about the
[ __ ] what my guy you know anyone goes on
the road and you're getting [ __ ] you
don't know how strong it is you're
getting it from random people I think he
had been sober and his tolerance was low
and just tried to go back to what had
gone was I think so but I don't know all
the details that [ __ ] need for escape
the need for the pill things doesn't
feel like though in general comics are
getting healthier like you probably you
saw the days when everyone was on blow
and everyone it feels like everyone's
now in Jamba Juice and on it and
kombucha and the real problem is I can't
imagine you know I mean we've never lost
our balls some people think that in
order to be a comedian you have to be
at least a little bit self-destructive
like the great ones just have good story
to get good stories yeah I started go to
therapy I was like [ __ ] what do I talk
about paying my mortgage on time pretty
funny it's a problem become wealthy
right you know how many fear of you know
your bills are paid when you stop doing
desperate [ __ ] and making mistakes you
just have less interesting story
certainly there's that but it doesn't
always have to be stories right but I
also think its perspective gets very
skewed when you live a life of leisure
yeah you know when you live a life of
leisure and comfort and privilege which
most wealthy comedians do that's when
they all start to suck like when
comedians have usually they have a few
good years like they make it and they
have like one or two good specials and
then they have some that just what
happened sloppy because you think they
just don't have to fight as hard or I
think a lot of times I hear you know
people will schedule their special like
I'm shooting your special next March
it's like but have you written it like
you scheduled it before you're finished
with that's the Eddie Murphy thing oh
really you know Eddie Murphy just got a
seventy million dollar deal he hasn't
done stand-up in 30 years so like how
many times does he get look I think
first of all just as an aside or just to
start this off I'm not bashing him I'm a
giant Eddie Murphy fan anybody who
thinks that Eddie Murphy should do stand
up again it's me and I've even talked
about on this podcast that he did that
he did some speech on a podium where
he's talking about how bad Bill Cosby
[ __ ] up because they had a he had to
give his his awards back you know oh
right oh [ __ ] it was hilarious segment
it's a Hilaire and I was like god damn
his timing is so good I wish you would
do stay on the Ganges well he was at the
Comedy Store walking the halls a couple
times I've done Tuesdays this was like a
couple years ago and he just walked in
and he just like looked like he was on a
people mover he was just a float through
the hallways and you know the hallways
it's like [ __ ] Beirut in those
hallways and everyone just gets super
quiet now and it hasn't done stand-up in
thirty years that's how god damn like
you know as nice as look Tim Allen is
Tim Allen hasn't done stand-up in
forever either but if he walks by but I
saw that's that guy from home
improvement yeah
they're not like freaking out that he's
there he was so good
during delirious and we were kids he'd
watch that you but he was so goddamn
good that today I mean Robin legend of
it just carries on I mean the real
question is when he comes back or people
gonna start tearing apart his old
specials and saying honey phobic and he
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah work like well
people are going after people for George
John Wayne John Wayne he's canceled his
cans like okay he's been dead for
decades escape he's not woken up in the
70s he said bad things about black
people or something no well there's [ __ ]
now where it's like Picasso's canceled
he's canceled yep Picasso's get Bukowski
is canceled man this is like the [ __ ]
and husky was in a Barbera or whatever
her name is
what's her name Hannah gasps me [ __ ]
think about Picasso like hey baby you
got to let that go that was a long time
he admitted I mean it's like that's the
other thing is all these people who put
their mental illness and struggles on a
kid they would probably agree with us oh
for sure they were [ __ ] up for she
know like van Gogh was shitty to his
subjects it's like yes oh I mean you see
it in his work
[Applause]